here's Crosby gaining The Zone his pass blocked
off the hand of Mel grin back to Center and
Carlson with it now stung him a little bit Jake
Kel on this number one unit for Pittsburgh their
power play 21st right now in the NHL a wrist
shot they score Riley Smith and it's one nothing
penguins with a power play goal pretty simple
on this power play they do a good job along
the boards keep the puck in they move a little bit
towards the middle watch in front Jake gensel does
a nice job screening I mean that is a beautiful
screen by Jake gensel and you just shoot the puck
towards the net sharks aren't able to block picked
up in the top Corner goal score fine that's it you
got to move on now as Hopman Came Crashing to the
net here's Smith back the other way Malin takes
feeds rust looks gives it to patteron back across
they score it's Riley Smith again and it's two to
nothing on the way back the Pittsburgh Penguins
counter and they get a bit of a bounce here Riley
Smith in the right place at the right time the
Sharks had a change they had a change as they were
coming back the Penguins were on the transition
the Sharks changed I don't think it was a great
change and that caused them to be behind the play
and that's why so many Pittsburgh Penguins were
jari two-time Allstar injured last year in fact he
got hurt in the Winter Classic game only played 47
games but that mattered not when it came contract
time they gave him a fat new 5-year deal here's
tryan rust they score Jake gensel a net crash goal
and it's three nothing skating off the puck gensel
coming on the wide side and he doesn't get picked
up early enough and he gets the inside right so
there's what gel does it's really smart doesn't
stay to the back post once he gets that lane to
the net as the Sharks try to pinch up with the
blue line he starts to cut to the middle and
he takes the angle where he's got the advantage
Kena runs into nto penguin with a delicate line
change there and they just did execute it fairly
as nto goes between the legs flips it in and now
ACH and after it against kop and they score
Vinnie hinestroza in his Pittsburgh debut two
quickies for the visitors it's four nothing it's
pretty simple right here the San Jose Sharks get
the pock in their bound they just want to kick
it to one side but Vinnie hinza is there there's
nobody there for KES off to push it to better
option here better play would have just been
to eat it take the hit protect the puck instead
tries to move it h stros is there Banks it off
ofin now hurdle diving down was Graves and the
puck ends up right to him McDonald able to keep it
in hurdle backand pass to Clair he scores Anthony
declair a power play [Applause] [Music] goal this
is a really good play by the sharks they keep
the puck in the zone and they move it right
down high low but what a move by toas hurdle
what a move look at that stick handling moveing
just on the back hand but what does duclair do
he doesn't stay back and wait for the puck he
goes into that scoring position he got a man
by the net and then you have to respect that
right talking to toas hurdle on that the
play though kept in on the puck kept in
in the zone I should say by Jacob McDonald
and quickly down low for the attack to the
net Riley Smith in the attacking
Zone to Malin and he scores it's
snuck through the five hole underneath
Blackwood and a big response goal for the
Penguins so this is the Penguins as you said
responding work along the boards then Malin
releases malin's really smart here this is
a smart play by a terrific hockey player
he releases as he sees the penguins getting the
advantage along the boards so Riley Smith's got
a three-point game going that primary helper for
Malin along with his two first period goals here's
Crosby in alone drops it for let's tang and he
scores and it's 6-1 and two quick ones again for
Pittsburgh transition again a beautiful
pass by cydney Crosby and Letang the dman
up on that play a really nice play by Sydney
Crosby but it was a transition Again by the
Sharks Carlson will steer it up the boards
henrosa goes up ice for nto Matt Neo three
onone aari shoots save they score Matt nto
he has a goal for the Pittsburgh Penguins
his first for them and it's 7-1 this situation
if there's no F3 there's no high forward now
that creates that situation where you've got an
outnumbered attack so you cannot chase you have
to make sure you stay with your structure
the sharks are trying to chase some offense
cuz they're down that has the pinch that
has no support on that pinch as that F3 is
gone Pittsburgh scored their goals on just
25 shots in what's particularly interesting
looking at the staff through 40 minutes
through only three Pittsburgh skaters
don't have a shot on goal the offense has
coming from up and down and throughout their
lineup well that's what they've been looking
for gel to the net a backhand by rust and he
scores that's too easy it's 8-1 with sharks
working in the corner and the numbers look
at the numbers here's declair in against Shay
still has it back hands it off the outside of
the cage hurdle Maks it through to granin in
front for duclair now back to McDonald here's
McDonald and he [Applause] scores Jacob McDonald
unloads a slap shot on the power play to make it
[Music] 82 good work entering the Zone good work
setting up below and the look at Mel gr kill to
the front of the net and then it's just a bomb of
a shot set it up from the point one timer Jacob
can shoot it a little bit of a screen but then
Joseph keeps it moving along those far boards
and now Laten trying to flip one through to
Riley Smith good stick by Kyle Burrows to get
in the way of that got get over there and help
Kell off the boards and over to Joseph back to
Chris lat Tang a pass in front Smith door step
bang bang play and Malin has his second of the
night the key is right there the play along the
boards Pittsburgh comes out with it and and then
malan rolls to the front watch him take this off
his foot though here Banks off the foot into the
I mean but then the Sharks chased it right they
chased the they gave a couple away and then they
started to chase their offense to try to get
it back there's more errors of commission than
Omission as compared to the Vancouver game
but still it's 9-2 Top Line on here rust at
the net thrown a battling for it in the puck
went in and Pittsburgh has double digits it's
102 maybe crossby can as the play goes to the net
just Center it to the net right and it looks like
yep it's gel you're right yeah the Penguins
put up double digits on the scoreboard at sap
Center that'll do it